michel onfray philosophe essayiste
bonsoir michel onfray merci d'être avec
nous nous avoir accordé cet entretien en
direct sur arte france avant la question
qu'on a souvent dû forcément vous poser
pourquoi front populaire votre revue
n'est pas nécessairement une coalition
des partis de gauche dont je vous avais
fait une présentation qui est un peu
différente on n'a jamais dit qu'on était
nationale ou nationales souverainiste je
sais pas d'où vous sortez cette
expression c'est pas une ou deux sont
nos ennemis qui disent plutôt ça ensuite
je n'ai pas dit que nous souhaitions
réuni 1 et souverainistes de droite et
de gauche points mais de droite de
gauche d'ailleurs et de nulle part c'est
pas exactement la même chose
oubliée la moitié de notre proposition
puisque ce qui nous en veuillent veulent
absolument imaginer que je dis de gauche
et de droite pour dire c'est surtout de
droite et pas du tout de gauche donc on
peut lire absolument sûr toutes les
colonnes des médias aujourd'hui qui vous
on a fait une belle tribune en tout cas
qui ont annoncé votre voilà cette revue
c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'on pouvait
lire absolument partout si tout le monde
le disait que c'est faux comme ça on est
au moins c'est très clair si toulon de
genre libération le monde
charlie hebdo france inter france
culture si tous les gens disent à peu
près la même chose d'ailleurs ils disent
toujours la même chose
le premier qui a menti donne le ton à
tous les autres qui vont mentir et qui
vont continuer de mentir
donc je vois des gens qui depuis plus
d'un mois sont en train de parler d'une
revue qui est en kiosque depuis 24
heures 48 heures donc bernard henri lévy
a estimé que j'étais jacques doriot
jacques doriot est quand même quelqu'un
qui a porté l'uniforme nazi sur le front
russe qui était fasciste je gagne à un
délire complet de la part de tous ses
journaux discussions finalement
propriété de 2,2 même famille de
milliardaires qui sont d'ailleurs
subventionnés par les uns pour de l'état
voilà donc des gens qui nous ont dit que
cette cette revue était rempli de
nationaux souverainistes de fasciste et
terrasses a fait 48 heures qu'on peut la
voir
et depuis 16h depuis deux jours
depuis 16 heures il ya deux jours j'irai
500 points de vente sont privés de la
revue parce que tout le monde se jette
dessus
donc voilà des gens qui parlent d'un
film qu'ils n'ont pas vu qui parle d'un
vin qui n'ont pas bu qui parle de livres
qu'ils n'ont pas lui qui parle d'une
revue qui n'ont pas encore eu entre les
mains
tout ça ce sont bien les méthodes de la
presse qui effectivement comme un seul
homme et ça c'est un peu ce qui les
caractérise donc oui elle dit des
bêtises et comme le monde est le premier
à dire des bêtises libération s'empresse
de lendemains de dire la même bêtise et
le surlendemain de france inter fait de
même et c'est donc plutôt la preuve de
ces gens là sont de connivence me dise
pas la vérité alors on s'excuse avoir
repris ses bêtises et on est absolument
ravie de vous accueillir sur un
entretien longue durée pour que vous
puissiez rétablir votre vérité parce que
évidemment c'est important cette
fiabilité
philippe bilger ne fait pas partie des
contributeurs non plus s'il voulait
qu'on reprenne les choses les unes après
les autres
philippe bilger lumineuse beaucoup
philippiques jamais et on l'a pas
approcher nous a pas approchés il ne
fait pas partie du comité d'action il
n'a pas donné de texte il ne fait pas
partie de l'équipe donc c'était parti
effectivement dit expliquer justement
ces fausses informations effectivement
qu'on a vraiment pu lire dans des
presses quand même sérieuses qui sont
supposés vérifier les informations d'un
journal le monde effectivement est
supposé quand même vérifier
l'information comment vous vous
l'expliquer et un manque justement de
vérification des sources où il ya une
volonté peut-être de mal présenter votre
projet dois-je vraiment sérieusement que
le monde est un journal sérieux vous
pose la question mais en tout cas il est
présenté comme tel oui il est présenté
par les journaux comme un journal
sérieux mais comme le sont tous copains
et coquins
évidemment le monde passons un journal
de référence mais ça passe pour un
journal de référence pour les
journalistes qui eux mêmes sont entre
les mains de quelques milliardaires qui
en plus de sa demande l'argent du
contribuable pour pouvoir faire une
propagande éhontée depuis une vingtaine
d'années donc ça fait bien longtemps que
je n'ai plus ces journaux là ou alors
juste pour savoir quel est le ton d'un
propagande mais non le monde n'est pas
sérieux outre le monde dit n'importe
quoi les propos vous avez repris en
pensant que le monde était un journal de
référence vous font dire effectivement
les bêtises que ces gens là disent nous
allons nous n'avons jamais été des
nationaux souverainiste nous n'avons
jamais été si nous sommes à elle par
exemple jamais sollicité philippe bilger
que j'aime beaucoup de lui
mais ce sont de fausses informations
sont lus que par les journalistes mais
on va tenter d'en savoir plus avec votre
parole avoue que c'est la seule qui
compte puisque c'est votre revue vous
lancer alors sur le web un j'espère
qu'on ne va pas se tromper cette fois
votre revue se décrit comme un parlement
perpétuelle des idées où le peuple
pourra faire des propositions pour
rebâtir notre monde alors cela fait qu
évidemment à certaines revendications
populaires qu'on a beaucoup entendu ces
derniers temps notamment du côté des
gilet jaune pour vous le peuple n'est
clairement pas assez entendu quand le
système actuel on n'est pas entendus
mais ensuite il est maltraité vous voyez
comment - qui suis maltraitée j'ai les
moyens de répondre parce
qu'effectivement vous m'invitez élire le
but lui même n'est jamais invités oui
pour cause quand on dit de lui qu'il est
analysée à bessines qu'il est un crétin
qu'ils votent mal qu'il faut l'éduquer
qu'il abatte -12 qu'il vit en province
que ce sont des paysans des plombes dp
corps des péquenots etc tous les tous
les jours ni gilet jaune s'en sont pris
plein la figure et comme par exemple on
a sollicité le peuple en 2005 en lui
disant voulez vous de ce traité européen
et mettre un coup d'accélérateur libéral
le peuple dit non merci nous ne
souhaitons pas cette europe là nous
sommes européens mais nous ne voulons
pas d'une europe libérale et bien en
2008 on dit au club
vous vous êtes trompé votre référendum
on l'envoie à la poubelle on va demander
au congrès c'est-à-dire l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat de voter contre
vous donc oui le peuple a bien compris
que on y faisait porter le chapeau
on a associé effectivement ligier les
jaunes à des casseurs alors que
finalement les casseurs c'était des
black blocs qui peut qui a enfilé le
gilet jaune y est parfois quelques
provocations parce que castanet
ministère de l'intérieur ne sont pas
contre ce genre de pratiques mais non le
peuple n'est pas fou et maltraités
humiliés moquer depuis 1981 mitterrand
est passé à droite il a persisté à dire
qu'il était de gauche et il a maltraité
le peuple ça fait un quart de siècle que
cette europe libérale dispose des pleins
pouvoirs et de la totalité de ces médias
qui font donc finalement sont des médias
qui ce qui endoctrinent donc à un moment
donné où le peuple il a essayé on a
compris au bout de trente ans
nous avions proposé des choses
formidables la fin du chômage de la
misère de la pauvreté la disparition du
racisme tout ça allait être merveilleuse
qui ont voté oui à maastricht lui et
libéralisme et puis on a eu le contraire
l'augmentation de l'antisémitisme de la
xénophobie de la haine de la
concentration des informations c'est à
dire que la propagande entre les mains
de quelques milliardaires
et puis ma sultan lieu et place de débat
s'est terminée aujourd'hui non plus
débattre on sait tout de suite insultes
et donc le peuple je dirai au sens large
du terme a bien compris comment les
manoeuvres à fonctionner et ne sont plus
prêts et je ne sont plus en plus t'as
pas mais maintenant d'en supporter plus
longtemps regardé ce gilet jaune combien
dieu ils ont perdu combien de mains ils
ont perdu combien de 2,2 de gens parmi
eux ont perdu la santé le maquereau
envoie la police contre le peuple quand
ils n'en voient pas la police il en voit
les résultats du référendum et là google
est ce que vous qualifiez votre revue
dans tes système où c'est un raccourci
que vous réfutez non notre anti système
marche on est juste en train de dire que
nous ne croyons qu'à la république c'est
à dire que la démocratie c'est le
pouvoir du peuple par le peuple pour le
peuple c'est une évidence et une
banalité et là ce n'est plus le cas le
pouvoir n'existe plus par le peuple pour
le peuple
il existe pour servir les intérêts du
libéralisme l'état français disparaît au
fur et à mesure l'autorité du chef de
l'état n'existait plus ça se voit
régulièrement de ce qui se passe dans
les banlieues tout de tous les gens qui
ont pu dire nous on a rien à faire par
exemple du processus de confinement on
sort quand on veut on fait ce qu'on veut
on peut faire des matches de football
sur des prières on va faire tout ce
qu'on veut on la marine mâchefer et il
ya effectivement un moment donné on se
dit cette république là il n'existe plus
nous nous voulons nous sommes des
républicains donc voulons reprendre la
déclaration des droits de l'homme en dix
ans il y a un droit par exemple à la
sûreté dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen de 1789 il n'y a
plus aujourd'hui de sûreté qui soit
assurée vous avez plusieurs centaines de
lieux dans la république française qui
ne sont plus des dieux républicain où la
loi de la république n'est plus les plus
actives
donc nous nous souhaitons simplement
nous redonner les moyens intellectuels
de
repenser le débat c'est que dans la
présentation vous avez présenté comme
une revue qui en gros prépare l'arrivée
d'un candidat aux prochaines
présidentielles c'est pas le cas du tout
numéro départ nous avons voulu faire une
revue de réflexion pour qu'on puisse
dire qu'on était souverain sans être
forcément un nationaliste dans quelqu'un
belliqueux et puis par la suite on s'est
aperçu qu'on avait un afflux
considérable de lecteurs d'abonnés on a
passé les trente mille abonnés alors que
la revue n'était même pas encore en
kiosque que personne ne l'avait vu et on
s'est dit mais on a on a des obligations
on a des devoirs à l'endroit de ses
gestes de ces gens donc si on fait
remonter des propositions il faut que
ces propositions puissent être
praticable et qu'ils puissent
éventuellement être pratiquée donc après
ça prendra la forme que ça devra prendre
on est des empirique
on n'est pas parti en se disant on va
faire émerger un candidat pour les
prochaines présidentielles mais si la
question se pose on examinera et puis
après tout pourquoi pas mais les
français n'ont pas envie d'un second
tour avec mâcon et marine le pen
donc si intellectuellement on peut
contribuer à l'équipement de ce genre de
débat qui n'est pas un débat eh bien on
aura fait notre travail justement ce
candidat là on a compris que c'était pas
votre premier ambitions avec cette revue
contrairement encore une fois ce qui est
effectivement présent des dents dans
toute la presse l'ambition voilà d'un
programme de socle pour la
présidentielle en tout cas ce candidat
idéal vous le verriez comment pour la
prochaine présidentielle notre
aventurier autogestionnaire te dire
qu'on pense qu'il ya un génie du peuple
et que s'il faut régler les problèmes de
la médecine ils vont me demander à des
médecins des infirmières à des dames qui
travaillent ou à des hommes qui
travaillent dans les hôpitaux ou que
pour la pêcherie française pour la
paysannerie française pour l'université
l'éducation la recherche mais il vaut
mieux aller demander aux gens qui sont
compétents parce qu'ils ont la pratique
et la connaissance de leur discipline
ce que sont la proposition plutôt que de
demander à des énarques à des gens qui
ont fait science pour moi des gens qui
font de la politique un métier qui sont
dans la politique politicienne depuis
depuis des décennies de leur demander
leur avis nous notre modèle vous savez
dans l'histoire c'était dans les années
70 l'ips c'est à dire des gens qui
fabriquait des comptes et qui à un
moment donné se sont dits également on
va autant gérer notre notre aventure est
aujourd'hui avec internet avec le site
que mâcon a lancé le
jours du 18 jones pas par hasard c'est
notre appel à nous et bien non on dit
cette fête donc des cahiers de doléances
faisons des états généraux perpétuelle
c'est comme un coin dit que j'aurais qui
n'a évidemment pas fait et puis
remontant quelque chose qui va
ressembler à un programme et puis après
si ce programme sert à tel ou tel pour
autant et si un jour quelqu'un sort de
la société civile et qui peut porter
lui-même ce projet ce ne sera pas moi je
les dis eh bien on pourra on pourrait
parler au conditionnel on pourrait
éventuellement l'aider mais a priori
notre revue n'est pas là pour servir de
tremplin à qui que ce soit pour devenir
le chef de l'état on a bien compris vous
parlez de la république res publica la
chose publique ça veut dire que tout
finalement le système de la vème
république serait à revoir selon vous
parce qu'on vous le savez très bien il
donne énormément de pouvoir seulement
parce que ce n'est pas ton cela qu'il
faudrait revoir
vous nous avez la vème république et
martin je vous le dis sipa ne devrait
pas être un scoop mais là le mig mortes
depuis quand l'un des truites il reste à
peu près un tiers de ce qui était de la
constitution de 58 donc quand par
exemple en 1992 avait peut-être le
traité de maastricht la france renonce à
sa souveraineté
moi je dirais c'est 100% de la
constitution qui n'existent plus donc on
fait semblant d'avoir une constitution
dix ans à 8 soit seulement un conseil
constitutionnel qui va nous dire est-ce
qu'il ya constitutionnalité des textes
des lois mais ça c'est pour faire
semblant c'est terminé un pays dispose
de sa souveraineté cantine ne dispose
plus d'assez la souveraineté ça n'est
plus un pays donc la france n'est plus
souveraine une vraie pourquoi nous
sommes souverainiste et la constitution
ne sert plus à rien c'est un cetain
c'est ainsi qu'en papier donc je ne
repose propose pas le retour aller à la
vème république en disant reprenant le
texte de départ on peut imaginer une
sixième république et qui ferait sa
place à ce que le général de gaulle
appelait sur la fin
202 de son exercice politique par
exemple la régionalisation de la
participation
ce sont des façon particulière de faire
de la politique à nouveaux frais
c'est-à-dire pas en jacobins mais plutôt
un girondin en laissant une place
importante aux régions aux communes aux
départements au peuple lui même en
disant mais finalement le talent il
n'est pas chez les gens qui ont fait
sciences po et l'ena mais il est chez
les gens qui travaillent et qui ont des
choses à dire
c'est ce qui s'appelle du populisme
quand on a envie d'insulter les gens ont
dit qu'ils sont populistes mais moi je
c'est pour un populiste parce que
finalement l'alternative c'est populiste
ou populicide il ya ceux qui tuent les
peuples symboliquement métaphoriquement
et puis ceux qui estiment que le peuple
doit être l'épicentre de la politique je
vous le rappelle le gouvernement du
peuple par le peuple pour le peuple
alors un sondage qu'il a peut-être vous
faire sourire ou peut-être dans le fond
vous flatter en tout cas c'est pas nous
qui le sortent on sait le sondage ifop
pour valeurs actuelles à la question
seriez-vous prêt à voter pour michel
onfray à l'élection présidentielle de
2000 22
je vous laisse regarder c'est quand même
beaucoup 9%
alors ça vous inspire quoi ça ça veut
dire qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup
aujourd'hui devant finalement partage le
type d'idées que vous êtes en train de
présenter c'est surtout surtout ridicule
de vouloir que je sois candidat alors
que j'ai dit depuis cinq cents fois que
je ne veux pas être candidat
donc j'y vois pas pourquoi où il est
absolument que je sois candidat et qu'on
commence à tester en disant un corner
connais pas et cgt mis en balance avec
le billard que 96 % je crois des gens
connaissaient et qu'ils lui devaient
être 13% en face a dit quelque chose
effectivement des idées que vous portez
voilà au delà de votre personne ça ça te
dit quelque chose sur la société
aujourd'hui et sur la rupture peut-être
avec un système traditionnel système
effectivement des élites que vous
dénoncez parfois pas du tout c'est se
dit que c'est débile les sondages je
vous dis rien n'à aucun par exemple
qu'ils étaient capables en 2002 de nous
dire que jean marie le pen serait
présent au second tour il a aucun
sondage
et pourtant il y avait beaucoup il ya
beaucoup d'argent ils sont dehors ils
s'en font de l'argent en ce moment là
d'aller voir ça va bientôt commencer et
ça commence déjà avec ce genre de choses
il a aucun par exemple de ces sondeurs
qui a été capable de dire que gainey
jospin ne seraient pas présents deuxième
tour des élections présidentielles en
2002 donc les sondages c'est n'importe
quoi ce sont ces faits pour permettre à
des partis politiques de donner de
l'argent à leurs copains pour fabriquer
des des opinions des mouvements
d'opinion et on veut absolument
m'intégrer dans un mouvement d'opinion
mais je dis simplement je ne veux pas je
dis dès le départ donc je crois pourquoi
on continue à dire mais si michel onfray
était candidat est-ce que moteur y est
pour lui et il connaît pas connu s'il
était plus connue
faisons des unes et des calculs si plus
de gens le connaissaient combien retrait
etc
leur motion frais ça vous dit quoi de
faire 9% hypothétiquement mais avec des
données corrigées si tout le monde vous
connaissez ça fait plutôt 15% alors vous
en dites quoi
j'en dis que j'ai dit que ça ne
m'intéressait pas et que je vois pas
l'intérêt je ne vois pas l'intérêt
façon de parler je ne vois pas l'intérêt
de faire ce genre de sondages sauf à ce
que émane de la con et intérêts à
fabriquer des diversions et je le sais
assez malin pour pousser des gens et en
revenir d'autres par exemple on dire en
mille téléphone à tous ses adversaires
il a téléphoné à zemmouri la téléphonie
bigard il a téléphoné à finkielkraut
d'accord forme d'un mois il m'a
téléphoné
non pas du tout et je vais jouer mon
billet qu'il ne m'appellera jamais sûr
peut-être après maman entendu si on lui
rapporte
mais parce qu'il sait bien qui est
dangereux qui n'est pas dangereux il
sait bien qui est son adversaire qui ne
l'est pas il sait bien qui est flatté
qui ne l'est pas on finit toujours par
le savoir que ces coups de fil en
aiguille ils sont tous très heureux les
gens qui ont reçu des coups de fil
indien et résidents et bien moi ça
n'aurait pas d'être appelé par ce
monsieur qu'il faut savoir que je n'ai
pas l'intention de 2,8 rappeler parce
que ma souplesse sur le feu depuis plus
important à faire de lui parler
effectivement vous le disiez vraiment
début de cette interview beaucoup de
critiques
là on en passe et des meilleurs vous
seriez devenu national il sera si ce
passéisme manipulateur vendu à l'autre à
droite
j'ai même lu fasciste bon on vous a
qualifé même de revues nazi avant même
sa publication
cette voie là cette violence dans les
propos ça veut dire quoi que vous faites
peur vaut accepter oui l'état dans
lequel il se trouve
c'est à dire si objectivement j'imagine
ma biographie mois elle témoigne pour
moi j'ai fait une université populaire
à quand j'ai fait des universités
populaires du goût j'ai fait du
bénévolat pour toute ma vie j'ai dans la
ville que j'habitais argenton dans une
sous préfecture des expositions
peintures points de rang pendant dix ans
d'un jamais parler de ces choses là je
me suis se mettre à la porte de france
culture par le pouvoir les amener
journaux donnent encore parler non plus
dire une université populaire qui
existait un camp a été interdite par le
maire de caen par les universitaires de
caen mais ça on n'a évidemment jamais
parler non plus et puis d'un seul coup
on découvre que je suis nazi formidable
c'est sûr que j'ai écrit et plus d'une
centaine de livres j'ai beaucoup parlé
et je demande à ce que depuis 1904
vingt neuf dates de mon apparition dans
le dos dans le long du terrain dans le
monde des idées on trouve une seule
phrase qui vont trouver que je défends
les chambres à gaz des étoiles juive les
déportations les camps de concentration
l'idée que j'aurais dit des juifs que
c'était une race inférieure et qu'il
faudrait restaurer la supériorité d'une
race aryenne ou ce genre de choses c'est
ça un nazi alors si moi je suis un nazi
nazisme le nazisme c'est pas si grave
mais pourquoi tant de droit d'être
négationniste et révisionniste dans ces
cas là c'est pas grave le nazisme si
c'est michel entre les franchement
heures ils ont peur ils détiennent les
médias et détiennent le pouvoir
économique ils détiennent le pouvoir
médiatique il détient des pouvoirs
universitaires comme le pouvoir avant
l'édition dans les revues partout ils
font la loi partout partout partout et
ils ne veulent pas que quelqu'un arrive
en disant mais nous on est libre on
n'appartient pas des banquiers on
appartient pas de milliardaires on
n'appartient pas des publicitaires on
appartient au lecteur ce sont les
lecteurs qui font notre notre existence
il à apprendre bien mais ils ont
beaucoup d'argent que c'est normal mais
chalon très il aime beaucoup d'argent
oui j'ai fait à peu près une trentaine
d'années de bénévolat pour quelqu'un qui
aime beaucoup d'argent
et puis qu'on dise parce que dans
l'extra si effectivement un anonyme
extrêmement courageux qui dit que je ne
suis intéressé que par l'argent mais
j'aimerais bien ce monsieur dit les
intéressés par argent parce que voilà à
lui fait des clips et des confiance je
peux vous donner des noms de code daguin
qui font des différences à 15000 et
20000 euros ou des gens qui partent hui
joue en croisière sur un bateau avec
leurs femmes parfois avec leurs
maîtresses mais parfois avec leurs
enfants et qui sont payés 50 ou 60 mille
euros pour aller faire des reçus ces
diverses et multiples et qui parfois
utilise quelques-uns de mes travaux sans
les citer qu'on le dise effectivement
qu'on dise jalons frais il admis la fédé
conférence payer vingt mille euros pour
des jeux parfois des pharmaciens des
notaires qu'on fasse savoir que j'ai été
le philosophe de service sur des délits
croisière et puis à ce moment là les
joueurs ont le droit de dire que je suis
un et que l'argent m'intéresse je
demande juste des preuves
je veux bien être un nazi mais je vous
dis il va falloir qu'on m'explique où
quand comment de quelle manière avec
quels textes qu'elle libre quels
engagements ont manqué une panique
totale de tous ces gens qui sortent du
même terrier et les gens ne sont pas
dupes ils découvrent effectivement qu'il
y a un pouvoir qui tient qui tient le
peuple sous sa botte
et comme on le dit nous ils ont
les autres équipes font populaire avec
mon ami stéphane sinon bah évidemment on
fait peur à des gens qui n'ont pas
intérêt à ce qu'on dise que le roi est
nu
alors les contributeurs en tout cas qui
vous suivent y en a plein de divers
horizons jean pierre chevènement
philippe de villiers gilet jaune
jacqueline moreau des personnalités de
droite comme de gauche continue en
commun selon vous ils ont en commun le
souverainisme le souverainisme l'art de
dire quand
quand la la la la voiture est prête à
sortir de la route parce qu'on voit bien
qu'elle est en train de sortir de la
route etc et prend la direction du fossé
on reprend le volant on reprend le
volant en disant eh bien on reprend la
maîtrise du véhicule qui est en train de
se précipiter au fossé c'est ça le
souverainisme c'est d'abord une méthode
ça ne veut pas dire après que l'on va
continuer en avance en reculant ou en
prenant à droite ou un plomb à prendre à
gauche c'est d'abord reprenons les
commandes
et puis après si on reprend les
commandes c'est pour faire une politique
et cette politique je ne les ai pas clé
en main je dis simplement que nous
voulons la faire remonter du peuple
parce que je pense que l'autogestion et
la meilleure des choses
arrêtez de de laisser les pleins
pouvoirs à une bureaucratie à une
administration des politiciens
professionnels à des gens qui kiffent
honda politique depuis depuis des lunes
député année je pense à jean luc
mélenchon qui n'a jamais travaillé sur
sa profession c'est d'avoir fait de la
politique on en a assez des gens qui
font de la politique politicienne il
faut retrouver l'esprit citoyen de 2,2
des grecs par exemple ou des romains et
ce sont les citoyens qui font de la
politique sont pas des gens qui allons
faire une profession
donc nous c'est ce qu'on souhaite c'est
ce qu'on souhaite effectivement il ya
plein de gens qui qui se partageant le
fromage de la politique politicienne se
disent il faut absolument discréditer ce
type là insulte on le méprise on le
traitons le nazi et fasciste
une file refoulé jeudi droite ou de
personnages ce type entier de deux des
personnages intéressé par l'argent misé
1 lille 3000 qui croient quoi ces gens
là que l'on nous fait une revue pour se
mettre de l'argent dans les poches du
mot si vous voulez je dois vous parler
des notes de frais de par exemple
maurice szafran a estimé que j'étais et
que j'étais je faisais partie de ces de
ses nationaux socialistes d'aujourd'hui
et je n'ai pas fait des notes de frais
tellement terrible dans la maison du
caviar que l'on n'aurait en modérant les
virées support précédent donc il ya un
tas de gens qui ont probablement dit
à se reprocher et qui se disent bon sens
dans cette revue qui n'ont rien à se
reprocher ils ont des gens plutôt plutôt
sincère qui n'ont pas de casier
judiciaire et bien évidemment tous ces
gens là se déchaînent sans peur à
plusieurs mais ce que je me trompe je
vous dis qu on vous sent quand même
peut-être voilà touché peut-être blessé
par toutes ces critiques vous on vous
entend votre honnêteté votre sincérité
voilà vous sortez une revue pour
exprimer vos idées les idées de vos
contributeurs et c'est vrai que y'a
voilà ces critiques très violentes et on
comprend que ça puisse plus pour vous
agacer est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous sentez
blessés pour même blessure agacée oui
parce que l'on se dit mais ça fait vingt
ans que ça dure fait quinze ans que ça
dure c'est pas la première fois et j'ai
fait un livre sur freud il ya des années
et c'est plutôt de lire ce livre sur
freud était déjà en librairie cave est
déjà une cabale contre moi il y avait
d'ailleurs une pétition pour interdire
la diffusion de mon cours sur france
culture au nom de la liberté
d'expression et est bien la première
campagne contre moi et qui a été fait
contre ce livre là a déjà dit à cette
époque là que j'étais antisémite donc
l'accusation d'antisémitisme et les très
très ancienne une très ancienne
donc la première fois c'est blessant
parce qu'on se dit mais je suis pas
antisémite un livre en disant que freud
était un imposteur
en appuyant médire sur son oeuvre sur sa
correspondance sur ses aphorismes sur
ces affirmations même célérité dit que
la psychanalyse est une imposture et
17,1 blanchiment de peut pas
mieux dire
et bien que que c'est une imposture et
bien tout la même presse celle
d'aujourd'hui à qui mieux vaut mis
dessus il est parti comme un seul homme
à l'époque en disant que j'étais
antisémite
alors oui à cette époque là ça m'a
blessé et puis après j'ai compris que
écoutez si si vraiment les gens estiment
que je suis un nazi
alors c'est qu'on est tombé vraiment
bien ben c'est que personne n'est dupe
c'est bernard henri lévy qui estime que
je suis jacques doriot aujourd'hui mais
enfin moi j'ai pas de sang sur les mains
je suis pas c'est pas moi qui ait
déclenché les guerres en libye par
exemple qui suis responsable de l'état
dans lequel se trouve l'irak où d'autres
pays bombardé avec son assentiment ou
avec le fait qu'il est désiré que la
france bombarde partout partout partout
partout en palestine en libye en irak en
afghanistan au mali voilà un monsieur
qui demande à ce qu'on tue des
populations civiles
il ya peu près 4 5 millions de morts
musulmans depuis une vingtaine d'années
un peu partout sur la planète à cause de
l'impérialisme occidental
bernard henri lévy qui soutient cette
logique a dit que je suis jacques doriot
c'est à dire que je suis un nazi et non
je n'ai pas le trac je dors sur mes deux
oreilles
ça n'est pas parce que ce monsieur
m'insulte de pour autant j'estime que
sont insultés et crédible il ne fait pas
partie des gens pour lesquels j'ai
quelques estime que ce soit il
yad'autres à personne dans la vie qui
pourrait me faire de la peine en pensant
des choses désagréables sur moi alors
ils loin d'en faire partie je vous
assure que les gens de libération du
monde donc pas partie non plus ça n'est
pas mon monde
il ya des gens que j'estime parce qu'ils
sont honorables tous ces gens là sont
déshonorés déshonorant par nora me du
tout donc je tiens pour une quantité
négligeable leurs insultes
je vous assure que ça m'empêche pas de
dormir ça me fait plutôt sourire et ça
me donne plutôt une énergie décuplée par
ce que dans la rue je ne vois personne
me traiter de nazi ni fasciste mais
plein de gens qui disent bravo continuez
c'est formidable je suis pas d'accord
avec vous sur tout mais c'est bien ce
que vous faites je me suis abonné à
votre revue je vais m'abonner à votre
rue etc
et s'il faut choisir entre l'assentiment
de personnage corrompu dont bernard lévy
ou l'assentiment d'un chauffeur de taxi
de d'angle de dinde un serveur à la
terrasse d'un café où et c'est mon choix
est fait j'ai effectivement une
préférence pour l'assentiment du peuple
plutôt pour la ville un sentiment de
ceux qui maîtrisent le peu de chose est
sûre nous sommes dans un climat
extrêmement tendu aujourd'hui en sorte
de cette crise
on n'est pas sortis totalement
d'ailleurs sanitaire il ya eu ces
manifestations entre les racistes anti
violence policière clairement et ça sera
ma dernière question à michel onfray est
il aujourd'hui une fracture entre l'état
une mignonne guerre civile qui est
évidente et qui ne dit pas son nom c'est
à dire que l'état fait semblant de pas
voir sa vessie ses trois petits singes
là elle est maintenant les yeux les
mains dans les oreilles les mains devant
la bouche pas vu pas entendu on ne dit
rien ne se passe rien chacun voit bien
effectivement qu'il ya une centaine
d'enfants en france où la république ne
fait plus la loi et quand vous avez un
ministre de l'intérieur qui vous dit que
après tout l'émotion est plus importante
que la loi alors c'est fini c'est
terminé quand vous êtes un
de l'intérieur qui dit je suis prêt à
mettre à genoux à terre alors qu'il est
déjà un ventre à terre qu'il ait déjà
accouché est bien évident que tout est
fini que plus rien n'existe dans dans
cet état français donc on est dans une
dans une situation effectivement de
guerre civile je je crains que nous
basculions un jour ou le sang va couler
il ya un moment donné une quelqu'un va
tirer dans le tas il va y avoir une
grenade dégoupillée où des rafales de
kalachnikov et alors là plus rien de ce
que nous sera intenable
parce que le chef de l'état n'est pas
crédible parce que l'état a perdu toute
autorité et parce que on crache sur la
police qui fait un métier terriblement
difficile la police elle interpelle
c'est son métier d'interpeller les gens
dangereux agressif violent et armés
donc si on estime qu' il faut faire ce
métier juste avec des avec des des
petits mots dos des bisounours ou des
petits post it avec vous n'aurez pas ma
haine ça va pas marcher
si vous avez une violence illégale
illégitime
il y a un dans un état normalement une
violence légale et légitime
c'est le monopole de la violence légale
c'est la définition max de berre la
police et l'armée sont là pour ça et on
est en train de délégitimer la violence
légale
en dix ans les policiers sont dans la
violence dans l'agressivité sont des
fascistes etc etc
et puis en face on tient maintenant les
autres ils n'ont rien fait alors que la
plupart du temps tout toutes ces
affaires elle concerne des gens qui sont
des voleurs des trafiquants qui n'ont
quasi judiciaire etc
merci merci beaucoup michel en fait on
arrive à la fin de notre entretien
mer-sol avoir accordé en direct sur rt
france et on espère avoir établi voilà
quelques intentions sur votre revue qui
est sorti cette semaine déjà 26 mille
abonnements pour cette revue est
ressorti
merci à vous à michel onfray